police are trying to learn the motive
behind the deadliest mass shooting in
Texas history people in tiny Sutherland
Springs gathered last night for a vigil
near the First Baptist Church you have
heard at least 26 people were killed
there when a gunman opened fire on the
church during the Sunday morning service
about 20 people were injured the victims
range in age from five years old to 72
sources tell CBS News a suspected gunman
is Devon Patrick Kelly he served in the
Air Force but was discharged in 2014
Jeff Glor is near the scene of the
massacre in Sutherland Springs Texas
that's about 30 miles southeast of San
Antonio Jeff good morning Nora good
morning to you some of the 20 people
taken to hospitals here have severe
injuries police say the suspected gunman
Devon Kelly showed up at the church in a
black tactical gear a ballistic vest and
armed with an ar-15 type rifle they say
he was first seen at a gas station
yesterday morning at 11:20 he then
allegedly crossed the street and fired
shots at people outside the church
before he went inside that church police
say when Kelly left the church a
neighbor got in a gun battle with him at
that point Kelly left the scene and that
neighbor hopped in a car with Johnny
Langan Dorf as he pulled up to the
church we hit about 95 going down 539
trying to catch this guy until he
eventually lost control on his own he
just gave up he just kind of he went off
in the ditch hit a hit hit a hay bale
from what I could see and then he just
never moved after that he just hurts so
many people and he just affected so many
people's lives why wouldn't you want to
take him down
when officers arrived they found Kelly
dead with a gunshot wound we did talk to
the sheriff
earlier it's we don't know at this point
whether he shot himself or not the
sheriff suspects
so Kelly is a former US Air Force member
who served from 2010 until 2014 in 2012
he was court-martialed for charges of
assaulting his spouse and their child he
was sentenced to 12 months confinement
and received a bad conduct discharge we
mentioned some of the 20 people taken to
hospitals in San Antonio have severe
injuries and we are starting to learn
the names of the victims who were killed
Annabelle Pomeroy was 14 years old she
is the daughter of the church's pastor
he and his wife happened to be out of
town this weekend Joann Ward was a
mother of four Emily Ward was just seven
years old this is a small town of only a
few hundred people where everybody does
seem to know everybody else and the
community is still trying to process all
of this Devon Kelly came from the nearby
town as well his neighbors were
surprised to learn that he's the suspect
accused of carrying out this shooting
it's pretty shocking to find out your
neighbor just did something like that
I'm stunned I'm what's going through my
mind right now as I'm stunned I would
have never thought this from my from my
neighbor nor his son the second we we
knew what was going on we just ran over
there to help as much as we could
everyone I heard the gunshots and then
you ran
we know we're there to see and I told my
wife did call was in County because that
was gunshots and it was in the
neighborhood to stop what we're doing
start to pray and see how we can serve
and that's what you're seeing right here
this community is rallying around these
folks together and help out because
these are people family that we knew and
as investigators continue looking into
Devin Kelley's background this morning
we will send it back to studio 57 in New
York Jeff thanks